what's it called like love Island and
there's like a Korean version which is
dope but then that we watching the
regular American version the guys on
those shows man again I'm maybe the
straightest person ever talking about
like like railroad not the [__] that
turns either straight straight one way
downtown Pittsburgh like that and we
were watching those dating shows my wife
and I and I'm like yeah the girls are
fine they're all fine as hell the
boys I am so straight they all like
Charming are they real alpha males but
subtly bro it was this one guy was like
putting this hardcore game down he was
like I really just find you
exceptionally attract creep yo bro no no
but he did it with so much goddamn
conviction he cooked her ass he's like
I'm really into and I really think we
should do something and she's just like
okay okay and I was like if I was her I
would be king myself yeah with
lust